police in idaho say they prevented a
possible domestic terror attack over the
weekend 31 men were arrested all dressed
alike allegedly on their way to wreak
havoc at a pride event in the city of
coeur d'alene
they were found standing in the back of
a u-haul truck all had traveled from
different places and police believe they
are members of a white supremacist group
senior investigative correspondent
katherine herrich is following this for
us catherine good morning good morning
nate the fbi is assisting local police
in the investigation for now each of the
31 people arrested faces a misdemeanor
charge for conspiracy to riot law
enforcement believes the participants
are connected to a white nationalist
hate group
they came to riot downtown court
delaine's police chief said it was clear
that alleged white supremacists intended
to start a riot before they were taken
into custody near a pride celebration
saturday authorities recovered gear
including shields shin guards and a
smoke grenade these guys stopped a
u-haul full of dudes a witness tipped
off police after watching the group load
into the back of a u-haul truck at a
hotel and said they looked like a little
army they appeared to be affiliated with
the group patriot front groups that
monitor extremist ideology say patriot
front promotes fascism and the creation
of a white ethno state it was founded in
2017 after breaking off from a neo-nazi
organization that participated in the
charlottesville virginia unite the right
rally the man convicted on federal hate
crime charges for driving his car into a
crowd of protesters and killing one of
them was affiliated with that original
group they are twisting and manipulating
and misusing the idea of patriotism but
promoting a white supremacist version of
patriotism cynthia miller idris tracks
domestic extremism at american
university and told us patriot fronts
members are overwhelmingly young white
men the group arrested saturday ranged
in age from 21 to 36 and were from a
dozen different states none was local to
coeur d'alene what does the incident in
idaho tell us about the overall threat
picture we're seeing
this broadening out of the targets that
people
across this supremacist spectrum are
choosing to intimidate or harass or harm
it is part of a broader
range of anti-democratic and extremist
types of events that are happening
in this case the apparent target was
that pride event which organizers say
was the largest north idaho has ever
seen as for the 31 defendants police say
they're scheduled to be arraigned later
today they include patriot front's
alleged leader gail
all right catherine thank you very much